[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS CARTLAND: Welcome to
Google+ Developers Live.
My name is Chris Cartland, and
I'm a developer programs
engineer working on the
Google+ platform.
I am joined today with Gerwin
and Allen, two of our Google
Developer experts, who have been
nice enough to join us to
talk about the cool projects
that they've been working on.
So this is really great.
We get to see not just me
talking about the features
that we have.
But we actually get to see the
people who are actually using
them to do cool things.
And they're really good at what
they do, and they'll be
able to talk through the reasons
behind why they make
certain things.
And so you can get a really good
view of their experience.
We hope you enjoy today's
showcase.
So can each of you introduce
yourself?
Maybe start with Allen.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Hi.
I'm Allen Firstenberg.
I'm a developer out
of New York.
I do a lot of work with the
Google+ Sign-in and the
Hangout API on the Google side,
and I'm starting to
branch out into stuff involving
Google Drive and
Google Glass.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Great.
Thank you.
Thanks for joining us.
And Gerwin, can you introduce
yourself?
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
Hi.
I'm Gerwin, developer
from Austria.
I'm doing a lot of stuff with
Google Hangouts API, the
Google+ API but also with all
sorts of different Google APIs
that I can get my hands on
or can't get my hands on.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's
awesome.
Well, thank you also
for joining us.
So today we're going to have
each of them talk about some
of the projects they're
working on.
And then we're going have a
little bit of a discussion
about Google+ and
Google+ Sign-In.
And then, of course, we'll
talk a little bit about
upcoming Google I/O.
So to start off, Gerwin, can you
tell us a little bit about
your Hangout app called
Draw Here?
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
So I have built a Hangout app
that allows you to draw stuff
on your video stream.
And I think the best way
to show it is to
actually show it.
So what it can do, I have here
a cursor, and I can actually
use this to draw directly
on my media stream.
Now if I could draw nicely, this
would actually look nice.
But it can do other stuff.
Just change the color, and
I can do rectangles.
And one thing, I think, is nice
about it, you can use it
for fun stuff, like just drawing
flowers or something.
But you can also use it
like a whiteboard.
You can use it to create some
sort of whiteboard in your
app, and then you can
actually use it to--
Let's just switch to
a [INAUDIBLE].
Let's make this one smaller.
And then you can just
do it to show off
calculations or something.
So you can use it for all sorts
of different stuff.
And I think it's pretty cool.
So you can use it for
educational stuff.
You can use to show stuff.
And one other feature you can
use it for, you can actually
use it to show photos
to your--
Viewers, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to just share a
screenshot of the app itself,
so you can see it.
So what I do is just drag the
screenshot into the app.
And you'll see the screenshot
now directly into this.
And they can actually
draw on the
screenshot which I imported.
And as you can see, what is
happening is on the one side
you have a drawing
canvas where you
actually do the drawing.
And what happens is whenever
you update something on the
drawing side, it updates an
overlay which is displayed
above your video stream.
So that's what's happening.
And you have some tools here,
like there's square, circles.
You have an eraser.
And you can draw images, and
then you can just remove the
image and you're
back to normal.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
That's great.
So what you're doing here is
using the overlay to get
whatever you want onto the
screen, which is really cool.
What do you think this
means for developers?
Because some people will want
to use this right away and
just be like, yeah, this
is fun to draw.
But where do you think--
and either of you
can chime in--
this might go, as far as what
this technology can do?
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
So what I've discovered is that
actually the overlays can
be updated rather quickly.
I managed to get ten frame
updates per second.
So what this means is that you
can actually use it to just
illustrate a lot of stuff
without other people having to
install an app, because it's
displayed directly on your
video feeds.
The only limitation is the
video transfer quality,
because it can get a little bit
choppy if you're on a slow
connection, because the video
image [INAUDIBLE].
So the technology behind this
is actually pretty easy,
because it just creates the
overlay from whatever source
you want to create it from.
So in this case, because I'm
having the canvas, I'm just
taking the data URI from the
canvas and creating an object.
But you can use it, for example,
if you and a family
friend you have some family
pictures, you have some
vacation pictures which you
want to show and you don't
want your grandparents to
have to install another
application.
You can just put the photos
in there and show
them to them easily.
So there are a lot of use cases
where you can use the
overlay in Settings.
For example, if you're in the
Hangout On Air, you can't use
other applications,
because they won't
display on the screen.
So you can use this method to
just display content of
whatever kind to the audience.
So you could actually have
animated lower [INAUDIBLE]
like you see in some news,
where you have the stock
prices going from down below.
So you can use it for those
kinds of settings, where you
have live pictures coming
in in your overlays.
So you could use it
News settings.
As I said, the update
is pretty immediate.
So that works quite nicely.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's
really cool.
And I see two things that are
really cool about that.
One is that it's really easy for
any application to put any
data into that view.
So you happened to make it a
drawing app, but you could do
other things with that.
And the second thing was that
you don't need everybody else
in the Hangout to actually use
the app or join the app in
order to see it.
So for example, right now I'm
not using the Hangouts app
that you wrote, but I'm still
able to see the things that
you draw on the screen.
And so those two things
are really cool.
And it makes it a pretty
fun application.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Yeah.
I think there's a lot of
power to overlays.
It's probably one of the most
powerful features that we have
right now that's been explored
as part of the Hangout API.
And we see a lot of different
uses of it, from the simple
lower thirds that we see in
things like Hangout Toolbox,
to the very dynamic
aspect that we're
seeing in Draw Here.
I think that's really the
place that's rich for
exploration in the
API right now.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And Gerwin, you
said that this looks like
it might be a lot of work behind
the scenes to make the
Hangouts part of this work.
And can use say a little bit how
difficult that was or how
easy that was?
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
So actually the Hangout part is
the easy part, because you
really just have an image URL,
or you have a data URI.
And you just create an image
resource from it, and then you
just display the overlay.
So actually, the most difficult
part about it is
because I work with more than
one layer is that, at the
moment, the API doesn't allow
you to define the order in
which they are displayed.
So if I want to put one layer
above the other, I have to
make sure I create them
in the right order.
And if you want to change the
order, you have to remove all
of them and create all of them
in the right order again.
So that's maybe the trickiest
part about it.
But in the end, it's just take
the image URL and put it on.
And that's three lines
of code, really.
CHRIS CARTLAND: OK.
Cool.
So those three lines, you can
put your image data however
you create that and do that.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's
very awesome.
Cool.
Yeah.
Well, thanks for showing
that to us.
That's a pretty cool
application.
And also, another thing that
Allen wanted to show is a
different app.
We'll switch gears a
little bit here.
Thanks, [INAUDIBLE]
for Draw Here.
And this one's called
Where Am I?
So Allen, can you tell us a
little bit about this app?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Sure.
Where Am I?--
I'll see if I can bring it up.
I'm not sure how well you can
see it-- is a simple app that
was built based on request.
A couple of people came to me
and said, hey, is there a good
way that we can share the URL
for the Hangout or the Hangout
On Air that we're running with
other people, either through
email or through chat
or through some
other social networks?
And I said, well, we have access
to that information.
So I wrote an app that would
display it, and as part of
that, I made it so that it
would shorten it into a
Goo.gl short URL.
And then they said, hey, it
would also be great if there
was a way that we could get
access to the YouTube URL and
that other people in the Hangout
with me can also see
that same YouTube URL
before we start.
So I added that.
And then they said, hey,
wouldn't it be great if that
everybody who joined
automatically joined Running
Hangout Toolbox?
So I added an option
to do that.
And all of these are
making use of--
[TELEPHONE RINGS]
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: --the
same part of the API.
Hang on just a moment.
Making use of the different
parts of the Google APIs that
are out there.
So the URL shortener
is one API.
It makes use of the Hangout API,
it combines it with some
other features, and puts it
all together in a concise,
simple way to do things and make
it available to everyone
in the Hangout.
So for example, the YouTube URL
under the current API is
only available to the person
who starts the Hangout.
And I was able to make use of
the shared state that's part
of every Hangout and put the URL
into the shared state, so
anybody who's running
the Where Am I?
App has access to it.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
That's really cool.
And what I think is really
great about this is it's
really great that you were able
to just keep saying, hey,
wouldn't it be great if?
And every time you asked that
question to yourself, you just
kept going and adding one more
thing, one more thing.
And you ended up with a lot of
different features in a pretty
simple app that is still
useful for the
people who use it.
[TELEPHONE RINGS]
CHRIS CARTLAND: And
now we need a turn
off phone call extension.
I wonder, wouldn't
it be great if?
No.
That's great.
Yeah.
That's a really cool
app, Where Am I?
So those are two cool apps that
actually run in Hangouts.
Let's switch back to Gerwin to
talk about something a little
more technical and what
he's done with Dart.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
So I've been looking into Dart
recently because I met up with
some of the Dart team recently
and some of the Dart developer
experts, really.
And they really got me
thinking, OK, let's
just try out Dart.
And of course, usually when I
try out new things I try to
combine them with things
I already know.
I know Hangouts really well, so
I thought, OK, how would I
go about writing a Hangout
application in Dart?
And what I ended up doing in
the end is wrote a complete
wrap-around the Hangouts API,
because the Hangouts API needs
JavaScript calls.
But in Dart, you can wrap
JavaScript calls into a scope
so you can access it.
So what I did is write the
complete start wrapper for it.
And the nice thing about it is,
with Dart being a typed
language, you have all
the nice features of
autocompletion, so you don't
have to remember exactly how
all the different calls
are called.
So it was an on state change,
the onStateChange, because you
just have to autocompletion.
And I'm just going to quickly
screenshare how this looks
like in the Dart Editor.
CHRIS CARTLAND: OK.
Yeah.
That's great.
So you can take advantage of
autocompletion when you're
writing Hangouts apps,
which is something
you couldn't do before.
GERWIN STURM: So basically
I have here
included my Hangouts library.
And what I do here, I create a
new Hangouts API class entity.
And then I have here the normal
setup where I have the
onApiReady.add, where I have the
onApiReady events to do a
listen when the API is ready.
And once the API is ready,
I can do [INAUDIBLE]
stuff in here.
So if I have my main
API object--
And I have here the
autocompletion.
This might be a little bit
small on the screenshot.
But I have all the different
namespaces in here.
So I can take the namespace,
and in here I have the
onStateChange event,
for example.
Which listens for changes
in the shared state.
And Change--
StateChangeEvent.
Sorry.
And once I am in here--
Not this one.
OnState--
Oops.
Sorry.
That's a dot add here.
That's live coding.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Great.
GERWIN STURM: And then I
have the event in here.
And if I have the event here, I
have actually the properties
that are inside of this
event, which are
sometimes hard to remember.
So I see the StateChanged event
has the Edit keys, and
it has the metadata, and it
has removed keys, and it
actually has the full state.
So I can actually just access
those parameters.
And I have [INAUDIBLE] and can
cycle through the values.
So I think it's actually pretty
fun to write Hangout
applications in--
Wait.
I'm just going to end
the screenshot.
I actually find it's even
more fun than writing in
JavaScript.
Because in JavaScript,
you don't have the
autocompletion feature.
You just have to switch to the
documentation all the time.
You have to look up stuff.
And in this case, you actually
have the documentation
included in the library.
So I think that's a pretty
neat feature
CHRIS CARTLAND: Hmm hmm.
And to see what you did to
make this happen is you
actually wrote the library that
you're using to make an
app right now.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
I wrote the library myself
so I can access it.
So what I did-- just switching
the screenshot quickly again.
So for example, if we just go
here in the onStateChange, I
defined the event [INAUDIBLE]
itself.
And then inside the code, I have
all those js.scope parts,
which actually then initialize
the JavaScript call to the
actual API.
So I have the proxy calls
through the actual APIs.
So I actually wrapped it quite a
bit so I don't have to write
too much JavaScript
code in the end.
So I wrote the full library, and
then I actually included
the documentation for
all the parameters.
So you could actually make a
Dart doc out of it with all
the Hangouts API explained
for you--
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
That's great.
GERWIN STURM: --automatically.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's
pretty amazing.
And then I'm sure you're going
to be continuing to use this
library in order to make other
cool applications.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
So the only problem at the
moment is that somehow the
Dart to JS compiler doesn't like
some parts in there, so
you can't compile with the
JavaScript and run it in
normal browser.
You have to run it in Dart
VM at the moment.
CHRIS CARTLAND: OK.
So there's a couple things that
need to be fixed before
it's ready to go out.
GERWIN STURM: I'm not quite
sure, probably because I
dynamically load JavaScript
on the Dart site.
So there's something where the
Dart to JS compiler might be a
little bit confused.
I have not entered this
in [INAUDIBLE].
But I have no problem running
it in Dart VM.
It's just a very small
percentage of people will
actually be able to
run it that way.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And I'm
confident you'll be able to
figure out what the next steps
are with this project.
But yeah, that's really great.
And thanks for showing us.
Great.
Allen, you have another project
that you're also
working on, which
is with node.js.
So I'll let you introduce
that one yourself.
[PHONE RINGS]
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: As my phone
starts ringing again.
Yeah.
I'm working on a project with
node.js that's basically a
demonstration project
for using node.js
with the Google+ Sign-In.
And it's kind of meant as an
illustration for how to do the
hybrid authorization flow that
you guys have defined as part
of the Google+ Sign-In.
And let me share my
screen again.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So you're
talking about using the
one-time code flow, where you
send a code from a web client
to your server in order to get
your server authorized for
making API requests.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG:
That's correct.
So basically, what this lets
you do is to handle some of
the authentication with the
Google+ Sign-In button on the
client side, and it
will then send a
one-time code to the server.
And then your server can,
from this code, get an
authentication token and a
refresh token, which it can
then use pretty much as long as
the user has authorized the
app to run it.
The code is available
in GitHub.
Everyone is welcome to take a
look at it, comment on it,
criticize it.
The couple of notable things
here is that it uses node.js.
So it's JavaScript on the
server, and it uses a package
from Google that handles
accessing the Google+ library.
And in fact, it's meant to
handle accessing any of
Google's client-side libraries
through the node.js
JavaScript.
So this is a case where work
that's already been done to
create the Google+ libraries, to
create Drive libraries, to
create pretty much the
authentication libraries, all
of this stuff has already
been done.
And now it's just being
leveraged on the node.js side,
based on an additional library
that's coming from Google.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And this
is a really new
library that Google has--
It' not fully launched.
I think it's in alpha
stage right now.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: It is
still in alpha stage.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Right.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: It is version
0.2.5, when I last
checked it out.
And when I first started playing
with it, I found some
bugs and reported the
bugs, and they
got fixed very promptly.
So Google is looking forward
to people trying it out,
kicking the tires, finding where
the problems are, and
working to improve them.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
Well, it's great to see where
this is going too.
And that is a coverage test of
all of the authentication and
authorization APIs, using
node.js on your server.
So that's great.
Yeah.
Was there anything else that you
wanted to add about that?
I think that seems
really cool.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: It's
wonderful for me.
I released it as public code
because I think other people
can profit from it.
I know this is certainly the
code that's become the
cornerstone for just about
everything else that I'm
writing against Google's APIs
these days in node.js.
So it's now the cornerstone
of all my other work.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's great.
So speaking of Google+ Sign-In,
what's been your
impression over the
past weeks since
Google+ Sign-In has launched?
What have you guys been
doing to play with it?
And what do you guys
like about it?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Want
to start, Gerwin?
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
Sure.
So I think it's really
a neat concept to
finally have a unified--
I wouldn't even call
it Google+ Sign-In.
It's like a Google sign in
button, because you can use it
all those other APIs you want
to use from Google as well.
And so you could use Google
Sign-In before, but you never
had this unique button, which
is the same for all the
websites, really.
It's the same flow for all
applications that use the
Sign-In button.
So I think it's really good
that people know what to
expect when they click the
button, and I think that's
really important.
Because you could have some sign
in button on your page,
but people could never know what
happens when they click
the button.
But now with the Google+
Sign-In, they know, OK, so
that's going to happen, when
they have used it before.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I agree.
And I think in addition to that,
one of the great things
is it's actually simplified
it a lot for client-side
developers, even simplified
it, to some extent, for
server-side developers too.
The button takes care of a good
chunk of the legwork that
we needed to do.
So if you're doing client-side
stuff, you could almost ignore
authentication and authorization
issues, leaving
it to the Sign-In button to
handle it all for you.
And on the server side, there's
just a little bit of
additional work that you need
to do to get it right.
You no longer need to worry as
much about am I requesting an
online or an offline token.
What an I doing?
Do I need to set up my
redirects correctly?
The button's really handling
almost all of
that for you now.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
That's awesome.
I'm glad to hear
that feedback.
GERWIN STURM: One thing I really
like, from the user
perspective, is that you
now have this new page,
plus.google.com/apps, which
shows you all the apps which
you have to used with the
Google+ Sign-In button.
And it allows you to change
settings, allows it to change
the visible people to
the application.
And it allows you to change who
can see your activities.
And I'm actually not quite
sure how many people have
actively used this page, so I'm
just going to screen share
it for people to see
how it looks like.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And so this is
at plus.google.com/apps.
GERWIN STURM: Yes.
Slash apps.
And it actually lists
all applications
which you've been using.
And as you can see, I've been
doing some testing.
I have quite a few
apps in here.
And down here it tells you what
activities an application
[INAUDIBLE] and it shows you who
can see your activities.
And you actually can directly
from here delete all the
activities, disconnect
the application.
And I think that's a very good
start where you can actually
see what's going on, and you
actually have linked to
applications in here.
I think it's much better than
the previous system for the
way you have to revoke
the app access from
your Profile settings.
I think that's the way to go,
because it's much more
user-friendly than
the other system.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And it provides
more functionality.
So it makes it easier to control
the authorization that
you've granted to other
applications.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And it
also looks nicer.
GERWIN STURM: It's still missing
some functionality,
because you don't have
the other scopes.
You just have the Google+
Log-In scopes.
And you could have a Google
Drive scope in there or
Latitude scope or Mirror
API scope.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
So it hasn't surfaced all the
information in that UI--
GERWIN STURM: No.
CHRIS CARTLAND: --actually
yet.
It just has the Google+
information there.
But you could actually request
more access in your
application, which isn't
serviced in this part of the
display yet.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Yeah.
I think the neat part about app
activities-- aside from
the fact that it's a great way
for applications and websites
and so forth to get information
into Google+--
is also to see what Google as
a whole is using with them.
We know that app activities are
increasingly going to be
factored into search results
and Search Plus Your
World-type results.
So having users using your
application and you generating
app activities for specific
types of events is going to be
a great feature, and it's going
to be something that
users will increasingly be able
to take advantage of.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
And I like how you touched on
how this is trying to make all
of Google better.
Because Google+ really is
designed to be that social
core to everything that
we do at Google.
So we're really excited with
things like app activity,
where we can start surfacing
that information in places
that it's useful and meaningful
for users.
And so there's a lot of cool
stuff that we think we can do
with this, and we're
looking forward to
what we can do next.
Yeah.
Allen, if you want to talk
about interactive posts?
I think I've been seeing
a lot of activity
with that around recently.
What do you guys think
about that feature?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: About a
week or two ago, people
suddenly understood what it was
and how it can be used.
And we're seeing a lot more of
them cropping up since then.
I think there are some
great applications
for interactive posts.
I know that a couple people I've
talked to about it have
really started thinking of it in
terms of not just a way to
share things but a way to
actually have people more
directly interact with websites,
so that the post
itself could be talking about
a website and the
call-to-action part can
literally be a call to action,
actually doing something,
actually starting a program,
reading a particular
page, starting a
game, joining a Hangout.
All of these things are things
we're starting to see with the
call-to-action, and I love it.
I think it's a great new way
to interact with things.
I think people initially were
very concerned that it looked
like it was just going to
be all about buying.
And once more information came
out and once people really
started to understand that it's
doing things, as opposed
to just reading things or seeing
things, they got a lot
more excited about the
potential of it.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
Very cool.
Yeah.
We've seen a lot of interest and
a lot of thought into how
interactive posts can
make individual
applications useful.
Because there isn't a
one-size-fits-all solution for
different applications, because
it's a really powerful
thing that's deeper than
anything they can really fit
everyone perfectly.
And that's why we have a long
list of call-to-action buttons
that developers can choose.
Because your application is
unique, and your use case is
powerful in its own way, and we
need to make sure that you
have that opportunity to make
something really cool with the
interactive posts to help drive
engagement and make your
posts more useful to users.
So there's a lot of cool
stuff in there.
So are you guys going to be
using Google+ Sign-In, you
think, in your applications,
as you keep making more?
It's a new thing, but what do
you guys think of it so far?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG:
Go ahead, Gerwin.
You go.
GERWIN STURM: So I'm definitely
going to use it
more in the future.
Actually, for all the new
projects I started with the
Cloud Endpoints and everything,
I used the
authentication method pretty
much everywhere now where I
need authentication.
When it's possible, I'm still
trying to figure out how to
make it work in Chrome
extensions.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: And
I'm the same way.
At this point, I'm looking at
doing Drive development.
I'm looking at doing
Glass development.
And for all of those
applications, they
both rely on OAuth.
And if it relies on OAuth,
I intend to be
using Google+ Sign-In.
That's why I created the
node.js sample package,
because that's the basis of me
building off everything else
that I'm doing these days.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
That's really exciting.
You mentioned Glass, and I heard
a little rumor about one
of Gerwin's projects.
And I don't know exactly
what that is.
But maybe Gerwin can give us
just a brief summary of what
he's trying to work
on right now.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
So I did quite a few stuff with
the Mirror API without
actually having access to it,
because I am not US, and I
don't have Glass.
So I wrote my own emulator.
Because the Mirror API is a
discovery-based API, you can
just encrypt cloud endpoints
on App Engine.
You can create your own
discovery-based APIs.
So it just copied all the
calls, basically.
And what I did now, for an
example of how to use the
Mirror API, I used a Hangout
application, which I've
written in Dart using
my Dart wrapper.
And this actually takes
information from the Google+
API to tell you more about the
people inside of the Hangout
and displays them for
you for Glass.
If you're sitting in a Hangout,
like we are now, I
could just turn on Glass
and see, oh, Chris, he
is working at Google.
Didn't know that.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's
really neat.
So there's a lot of
pieces in there.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
So I'm just combining different
pieces and throwing
them all together and seeing
what comes out of it.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's
really amazing.
So to make sure I got all the
pieces in there, you have had
your Dart wrapper that we
already talked about today to
make a Hangouts app.
And with the Hangouts app, you
were using the Mirror API and
the Google+ API to bring
relevant content to the people
wearing Glass.
GERWIN STURM: Exactly.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's great.
Sounds exciting.
I'm looking forward
to the future.
That's awesome.
Speaking of what's coming up,
next week is Google I/O. And I
believe both of you will
be coming out--
is that right?-- to visit
us in California.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG:
That's right.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
We look forward to
having you here.
You think there's going to
be a lot of cool things?
What's most exciting?
Why would you make the trip all
the way out to California?
I know, Allen, you're
in New York.
And Gerwin, you have
even further to go.
How far is it for you
to travel, Gerwin?
GERWIN STURM: Well, I have to
fly to London for two hours.
And then I have a 10 or
11-hour flight to San
Francisco and lots of waiting
time in between.
So it's going to be a while.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
Great.
So yeah, what's really driving
you to make that long trip out
to California next week?
GERWIN STURM: So what I find
really exciting about I/O is
meeting all the people.
It's just like you have about
5,000 very enthusiastic
developers all in one
place, so there's a
lot energy in there.
And you can just go up to
people, talk to people, get
ideas, exchange ideas.
The talks might be interesting,
but you can
always listen to the talks
on YouTube later.
But it's just the time in
between the talks where you
have a chance to talk to the
Google teams, or you have a
chance to talk to other
developers working with the
APIs to see how they
are using it.
It's just all about the people
you meet there, which you
can't in normal life, which
doesn't happen so often.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: When I went
to I/O last year, it was the
first time I'd been to I/O. I
didn't know what to expect.
I went to every session I could
and talked to everyone
that I could.
And I found the sessions that
were most useful to me were
the ones that were most
surprising to me.
So I went to sessions on Drive,
for example, knowing
absolutely nothing about Google
Drive before then.
And in the year since
then, I've done
quite a bit with Drive.
I've learned a lot
more about it.
I had some questions about
Maps last year.
I stopped by the help desk and
got some really good answers
about how to continue and where
to get more information.
So I think that the best part of
Google I/O, as Gerwin said,
it's networking with other
people, being able to go up to
them and talk to them and get
inspired by some of what
they're doing.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
It should be a really
exciting time.
I'm looking forward to
next week as well.
For the people who are not able
to make it to I/O, there
are some I/O Extended events.
Last I checked, there were over
370, I think, Google I/O
Extended events around
the world.
And are there some in
areas where you
are, Allen and Gerwin?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I know
that there are three in
the New York area.
One of them is run by the Google
Developer group in
Manhattan, and a couple of other
companies are holding
their own I/O viewing events.
And from what I understand,
they're always exciting and
always interesting to follow.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
And we have one in
Vienna as well.
So we have our GDG Vienna
group, which is
organizing an event.
And we're expecting around 100
people, I think, which are
coming there.
And actually, my first
impression of I/O was an I/O
Extended event.
And actually, I/O Extended, it's
really like a small I/O,
because there as well you get
to meet other people who are
excited about the topic.
So if you're in an area where
you have an I/O extended near
you, make sure to go there,
because you get a lot of the
feeling you have at the I/O
at the I/O Extended event.
And most I/O Extended events
will actually have people from
I/O calling in for
the local group.
So I will probably call into
our local GDG Vienna group
through Hangout to tell
them how it's like.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
That's great.
And for the people who aren't
able to make it to one of
these events and aren't able to
be at I/O, of course all of
the talks will be recorded,
and you can watch those
sessions later.
Also, there will be a lot of
people posting on Google+ and
other places online about what
they find and what they learn
at Google I/O. So if you want to
keep up in real time, we're
going to be using the
hashtag io13.
So there's going to be a lot of
cool stuff that comes out
as people learn about whatever
the topics are.
We have a lot of different
tracks that you can follow.
For example, Google+ has a track
that I think has about
14 sessions.
So there's a lot of different
things and topics that you can
learn about.
I'll be giving a talk on
Cross-Platform Auth with
Google+ Sign-In.
So if you're interested in how
to use Auth with different
platforms, like Android, iOS,
and web, as well as dealing
with a server, you should
come out and watch that.
Was there anything else about
I/O that you guys are looking
forward to next week?
Anything else for the
people watching?
What should they be
looking forward to
and keep an eye out?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: The
keynote's going to be
exciting, because it's
always exciting.
But I really think, again, in
the spirit of networking with
people, follow people who are
going to I/O. A lot of them
are really excited about being
there and will talk and post
endlessly about what they're
finding and discovering.
I know last year I posted dozens
and dozens of times
during sessions about what I was
seeing, and it was great,
the conversations that
sprung up because
of what I was posting.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
And you can probably follow the
io13 hashtag, and there's
also the Google I/O community
where people will be posting
and talking a lot, I think.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
The Google I/O community has
already got some good
conversations going.
And I'm sure it's just going to
get better as we get closer
to the actual event.
Well, that's going to
be really great.
Thank you so much for joining
us today, Allen and Gerwin.
These people that you see in
front of me are great, because
not only are they making cool
stuff with our services at
Google, they're also
helping us out.
So when you ask questions in
the Google+ Plus developers
community, they're often
the ones that
are solving the problems.
And if you ask questions on
Stack Overflow, they're out
there helping answer them.
So I really want to thank them,
not only for joining me
today but for helping out and
supporting all the developers
around the world with Google+.
Great.
So thank you so much,
Allen and Gerwin.
And we'll hope to have you
on again another time.
And thanks, everyone,
for watching.
And we'll see you next week.
Or sorry, we won't see you next
week, because we'll be
getting ready for I/O. But
we'll see you soon.
Thanks so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]